dice has outlined its plans for the
future of battlefield 2042 and
unfortunately that includes delaying
season one to sometime this summer
dice said in a statement we are heavily
invested and committed to the future of
battlefield 2042 working on taking
action on multiple fronts to address
feedback and implement extensive fixes
to the game dice is also working on a
clearer tighter squad loop to help with
team play along with a refined ping
system players can also look forward to
an improved reward loop to help
encourage people to play the objective
dice is also looking at making further
changes to weapon balance while other
changes for specialists and the portal
mode are also in the works additionally
dice is changing how it communicates
with fans by outlining key points
including sharing the team's thought
process behind changes observing player
conversation around hot topics and
implementing all of the above to guide
decisions for future improvements and
changes in general dice said its
overarching goal is to better explain
the studio's reasoning behind any
changes it makes to battlefield 2042 we
want you to see more of the big picture
of where we're going and incorporate
more of what we're already hearing to
ensure our work is meaningful to you
dice said as for battlefield 2042 season
1 while it is to be the first of four
seasons on the way the delay also means
it'll be nearly a year before players
get any seasonal content however players
can expect for new specialists new maps
and more this summer
messaging platform discord has confirmed
that it is now gradually rolling out to
us playstation console users support for
additional countries will follow in time
and the process for linking your
playstation console to the app is
similar to linking most devices just
open up your discard app on mobile or pc
head to connections then settings then
add where you'll see the playstation
logo
then connect your account as you would
any other device and you're set
playstation users will have the option
of displaying their playstation network
online id on their profile giving their
discord friends a chance to add them to
their sony friends circle discord added
that this feature is also great for
games that have cross-platform support
and organizing a virtual meetup in
titles such as destiny 2 or fortnite for
example when sony announced its
partnership last year it mentioned a
move to focus on playstation network as
a hub for social gaming sony president
jim ryan said at the time our goal is to
bring the discord and playstation
experiences closer together on console
and mobile starting early next year
allowing friends groups and communities
to hang out have fun and communicate
more easily while playing together
it's been a big month of acquisitions
and here's another one for the list the
new york times has bought wordle the
viral daily word game creator josh
wardle says he is working with the times
to move the game over to the nyt site
where it will initially remain free with
your current win streaks and other
records intact according to a report
from the nyt the purchase was made in
the low seven figures it also said it
will initially remain free to new and
existing players but it also noted that
this is part of its strategy to grow its
digital subscriptions to 10 million by
the year 2025. the game currently has
millions of daily players wardless said
in a statement i'd be lying if i said
this hasn't been a little overwhelming
after all i'm just one person and it's
important to me that as wordle grows it
continues to provide a great experience
to everyone he said he has long admired
the nyt's approach to games wordle has
said in interviews including ones with
the times that he made wordle for his
partner due to their interest in the
times crossword and spelling bee to date
the game has offered no micro
transactions or monetization despite
others attempts to capitalize on its
popularity
how do you feel about battlefield 2042
season 1 not getting here until the
summer well if you need something to
hold you over in the meantime don't
forget to snag the ps plus free games
that drop today because it's the first
and there's a story refresh can we just
stop for a moment and realize it is
february first already
all right now that that's over leave a
like subscribe and as always come back
tomorrow for your next episode of
gamespot news
[Music]
you